what looks like a reptile amphibian
hybrid has a dish-shaped skull smells
like fish is childlike and out to steal
your crops and drown your livestock the
Japanese water yo-kai Kapa Capa
translates to riverchild but there are
more than 100 variations of the name and
while described as childlike in
appearance their behavior certainly is
not Kapa is a truly Japanese yo-kai
while some Yokai originate in China or
are inspired by Chinese folklore the
Capa is Japan through and through Anda
are obsessed with butts so hang on to
yours I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is
monstrum with so many different stories
of Kaa out there I knew I would need
some extra help digging into the lore of
this yo-kai my name is yoshiko okuyama
I'm a full professor of Japanese studies
at the University of Hawaii at Hilo and
I'm also the alsoa of Japanese mythology
in film personality wise the Kappa is
like the class clown with a Pinchin for
pranks sometimes a really bad one
according to Legend living in rivers
ponds and lakes Kappa are commonly
portrayed as green in color with a
turtle shell on their back partially
hollowed out heads and beak-like mouths
a popular cppa story is based on a real
Japanese feudal Lord K kumasa after a CA
drowns one of his favorite Pages he
orders the execution of all the kaas in
his Province Buddhist priests chanted to
keep the creatures in the area monkeys
were brought in to frighten the CA and
all the streams were poisoned and filled
with hot rocks scared and sick the
leader of the ca promised his kind would
never harm anyone in the region again
they were forgiven and kept their word
this is a common Trope in CA Tales often
times CA must promise to stop harassing
people and they must offer help to
people when needed or share their secret
medical remedies the copas were
especially Adept at bone setting oddly
enough their medical knowledge May
connect back to other water deities
associated with fertility or
agricultural deities especially in more
positive Legends since they were also
given offerings in the hopes of securing
good health in children outside of
making threats there are a few other
ways to survive an attack sometimes a
coopa attack on a human or livestock is
foiled when the yokai's arm is pulled
out of their bodies luckily for Capa it
can be reattached but they have a
critical weakness if they spill any of
the liquid from their unique head dish
it's going to be a problem let's talk
about that for a second the coa's head
has a divot that holds a liquid directly
related to the coa's life force you can
defend against a COA attack by wrestling
the Coppa or just by showing some
manners if you bow before your opponent
it will bow back spilling the contents
of its head dish and losing its strength
and maybe even its own life another
bizarre attribute of the cop
it loves cucumbers which is also the
reason why a cucumber sushi roll is
called kapam Maki a fun little reference
to this mischievous yo-kai less fun fact
if the cppa pulls you underwater it will
steal your liver or blood they will
often do so by a rather non-traditional
backdoor method why well they must
remove the shiroko dama first the
shiroko dama is a mythical ball-like
organ or Jewel that people have inside
their derrier that's the source of Your
vitality like your life's battery pack
and Mr Kaa wants it once it SN is your
you're out your body becomes like a
noodle all week and floppy in the water
ah talk about the way to L Mojo right
and a way to make it easier for Kaa to
drown you apparently this is a tasty
snack for Kaa who will consume it or
take it to their King as tribute and yes
some read earlier calore as symbolic of
male male sexual relationships there are
a lot of COA stories involving butts but
let's save that for the comments the COA
is often Associated not just with
violence and thievery but sexual
harassment and assault copper are almost
always male especially in the earlier
lore according to author kunio yanagi's
folklore collection the legends of tono
the Coppa will attack and impregnate
human women The Offspring of these
attacks are mercilessly killed chopped
into pieces and buried in wine casks
there are a lot of regional variations
of COA given its large Geographic range
they are often depicted as an amphibious
creature Japan is home to over 30
species of frogs and 17 types of turtles
so an amphibious water yo-kai makes
sense in eastern Japan COA commonly had
a turtle shell on their back while in
Western Japan variations were more
likely to be covered in hair and walk
upright I think these Kaa might be more
heavily inspired by the Japanese maak or
snow monkey who just so happen happens
to like to take hot spring baths in the
winter the association with CA to
Drowning humans seems straightforward
they might have been used to warn
children to be careful around water
think of the Kaa Legend as ancient
Japan's version of a no swimming sign
back in the day a written warning
wouldn't cut it right since most folks
couldn't read but a chilling tale of a
life snatching water creature would
stick in your head and they're a
reminder to protect livestock those are
valuable resources you wouldn't want to
lose makes sense but there's a bit more
to it in Northern and Eastern Japan the
copamore commonly pulled horses into the
water in these regions horse populations
were much higher than cows even going as
far back as the 13 Century there's
evidence of horse veterinarian clinics
in temples a clear sign of thein's
importance but over in Western Japan the
story center around Kaa attacking cows
this Region's leather trade was largely
dominated by cow skins and boasted the
epicenter of the Japanese leather trade
whether cows or horses the Copa threat
is significant in the 17th century an
unparalleled set of laws existed to
protect these and other animals from
maltreatment it was illegal to abandon a
sick Cow Horse and certain rules existed
around how to dispose of their corpses
in the late 18th century reports emerge
of peasants in rural communities being
charged additional fees for corpse
removal if the animal dies in fires or
from drowning
a cppa pulling a horse or cowle a watery
grave would be significant it meant a
loss of a valuable asset and a potential
fine in the early 18th century written
folklore of the ca developed and it gave
us the first recorded images of the
monster around 1713 terajima Rian
compiled a truly extensive encyclopedia
at a whopping of 105 volumes the entries
are accompanied by illustrations
including his take on a creature labeled
kataro which is is widely considered to
be the first illustration of aapa this
important entry into yo-kai lore is very
detailed described by Rian as about the
size of a 10-year-old child it speaks in
a human voice walks upright and has a
partially concave head that can hold
water while they favor a watery habitat
they are not above making their way onto
land to steal crops or enjoy a little
sumo wrestling a sport they excel in as
long as the top of their head is holding
water Rian also mentions the buz stuff
as in sucking blood from cows and humans
through their butts that might sound
ridiculous to us now but keep in mind
that yo-kai were presented in academic
texts alongside realworld animals this
blurred the lines between folklore and
fact that tradition would change
slightly in 1776 with the publication of
the first yo-kai exclusive beastiary in
Japanese history and you better believe
the ca is in there author and artist
Toriyama say
also added another detail to existing
Capa lore webbed feet with the
publication of this text the ca became
more rooted in folklore rather than real
history and less associated with danger
and deviant serving more as symbols of
Japan's rural history and that symbolism
carried into modern times for example
the 1923 Noll Capa written by Ranos
utagawa uses the Fantastical land of the
Capa as an intentional caricature of
post World War one Japanese culture
other 20th century creatives also depict
the creatures walking upright and acting
in more human-like activities a trend
that dominated the Capa of popular
culture after suzumu kan's Capa tangoku
introduced the Capa into manga in the
1950s the series centers around a family
of Capa engaging in everyday human
behaviors they eat shop and go to work
it was in this decade that shimuzu along
with artist koimo standardized the
female CAPA making CA more human pushes
them further away from being a monster
to fear light-hearted virgins continued
to appear throughout the 1970s where
they recalled a Nostalgia for Rural Life
and traditional Japanese folklore rural
regions of Japan publicized CA Legends
to encourage appreciation of traditional
Japanese communities and boost their
economies one of the most popular CA
tourist destinations is tono which just
so happens to be an important site for
the historic Japanese horse trade back
in the day Kaa continue to appear
everywhere anime manga books and
liveaction and animated films they
appear at advertisements and logos for
everything from sake to credit cards
their more nefarious Origins have turned
into a nostalgic nod to the past and
they sometimes move Beyond Japan's
borders in 1993 Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles 3 takes the anthropomorphic
Turtle Brothers through a time traveling
plot where they are constantly mistaken
as Kaa CA even popped up in everyone's
favorite cozy escapism game Animal
Crossing we also see evidence of the
ca's popularity in a form of modern-day
encyclopedia the database if there's a
fandom out there you can be sure there's
a fan base website describing and
categorizing the minutia of its Universe
the Pokémon Wiki monster Wiki or the DND
d wiki the COA appears in all of those
these collections of fan knowledge
aren't just about modernizing the Beast
year or encyclopedia they are part of a
global desire for connection the
appreciation for the folklore and its
Evolution can be shared around the world
and Capa in particular holds special
meaning in Japanese history as I stated
in my book Japanese mythology film we
have this innate desire to preserve our
cultural Traditions our ancestors
beliefs customs and even spiritual
practices myth are like the tapis
history of ancestral wisdom wom with
newly enriched threads as they have
passed down from generation to
generation I don't know something tells
me terajima Rian would be proud I just
said boasted not boosted it is boasted
cuz it would have boosted the leather
trade but it
boasted David you sound so positive we
got to go back to the
top